[Musique]
cette mixture là pour elle fait de la
régalade mange et une fois qu'elles ont
bien mangé elle rejette dont elles ont
pas besoin et ça sent mauvais on peut
faire des choses pour éviter ça on
supporte moins bien certains métaux que
d'autres et du coup ça peut surinter
éviter de tripoter tout le temps vos
bijoux d'oreilles et bactéries on en a
partout mais on en a surtout sur les
mains le problème on l'a vu c'est que ça
stagne et que c'est souvent un endroit
qu'on ne nettoie pas penser à laver vos
trous d'oreilles avec de l'eau tiède et
du savon doux voire du savon à pH neutre
pour ça commencer par enlever vos bijoux
et passer un petit coup dessus aussi ça
suffit pas vous pouvez utiliser du savon
antibactérien si vous nettoyez bien les
lobes et l'extérieur des trous en
appuyant bien dessus de chaque côté
c'est pas mal même si vous mettez plus
de bijoux ça peut arriver à des vieux
trous mal rebouchés de pas sentir très